this this room is my room now this is my
den this is my cave it go you have to
get in there before work though I will
build you another bathroom woman
what do you do April nice they on season
huh yeah yep not in August so you still
got a little bit of time left
yeah yeah oh yeah hey we should go good
luck buddy damn now pregnant two flaming
the hunt some extra side of fries two
wedge salads hold the blue cheese
crumbles after makin nice man eating for
two huh
whoa easy there little Steph there did
you just call our little Stephanie
that's so cute no no like Steph Curry
point guard of the Golden State Warriors
probably Rambo yeah buddy buddy buddy
touch my belly and he gave me parenting
advice
so assault is a serious offense okay I
can't let you go scot free punching my
belly was a threat to my dynasty I'm
just gonna let you off with a warning
I'm gonna chalk this up to pregnant
spring okay Jiki a thing just like you
asked
thanks babe do you guys have any advice
for Joey and I baby it's not a big deal
are you talking about it's huge so it's
a kid hurt that much of Earth to how
much people want that kids dude it was
the most gruesome thing that I've ever
experienced imagine a snake I thought
everything was just great
oh you make life yeah you make life hmm
go back to bed now mm-hmm we sleepy this
way mm-hmm